it's funny because I wanted to be a lot
of things when I was younger but I
decided at one point like hey it would
be cool if I was an actress and my mom
thought it was kind of funny she's like
oh it's a phase whatever years later
acting is clearly not just a phase for
Jenna Ortega from Disney Channel star
I was under the fridge and no one even
noticed to Bonafide big screen Queen
it's still such an honor to work with
someone like Ghostface is a it's a dream
let's snap back to when we first met
Jenna
the California Native started acting
back in 2012 when the then 10 year old
nabbed her first on-screen Credit in Rob
Schneider's self-titled sitcom give me
my baby back it's not your baby go away
I have a photographic memory so it's
super easy for me and in 2013 things got
even more marvelous when Jenna made her
big screen debut in a little flick
called Iron Man 3.
love you babe
and Through the Years Jenna consistently
added to her resume she made waves in
2016 when she nabbed the lead role in
Disney Channel's family sitcom Stuck in
the Middle Stuck in the Middle it's kind
of like my home how'd you find me Mom
Jacker same way I found you yesterday
behind the dryer she also played the
younger version of Gina Rodriguez's
character Jane on Jane the Virgin what's
definitely more relaxed at Jane the
Virgin and it's such a happy set I love
it there
[Music]
but then years later Jenna upped The
Fear Factor and landed a gig on you
Netflix's stalker Thriller series what's
your insta or do you only have a finsta
a little behind the times clearly it's
been amazing it's been amazing that cast
is so talented the response has been
amazing and I'm just so grateful to be a
part of it I love it she continued her
career Evolution with more serious work
like in 2021's the Fallout a drama where
her character survives a school shooting
the part that earned her rave reviews
when we it did come time to shoot the
more serious scenes or you know when we
would have days where it's like back to
back
um more dramatic
um
script pages I think that obviously on
those days we we respected what we were
shooting and we took the time to really
plan everything out and make sure that
what we're doing everyone's comfortable
with what we're doing but also that
we're giving our all what are you
feeling right now I feel
mad and by the time 2022 rolled around
Jenna claimed the crown as a certifiable
scream Queen it just felt appropriate by
starring in not one
not two
but three spooky projects in the same
year that boy's family was going to file
attempted murder charges
how would that have looked on your
record terrible
everyone would know I failed to get the
job done Wednesday I've always been
compared to and it's weird because you
never really
you sign out of this job but you never
really anticipate being offered or even
being in the run for jobs like these
with you know such icons and legendary
characters yeah it's it's pretty cool it
kind of felt like a future dreams
honestly Jenna's portrayal of Wednesday
shattered streaming records the show
scored a season two pickup and to the
actress got some killer praise so much
so she scored her first Golden Globes
nomination
[Music]
I definitely feel like there's been a
shift in my life and I feel a shift in
energy and change and I feel like it's
definitely a new time in my life so it's
it's been a bit of an adjustment gotta
give her a hand
our first order of business is to escape
this teenage purgatory
Jenna Ortega is absolutely slaying I
can't find her
[Music]